on a vu il ya un an deux ans et c'est
assez régulier les jeunes en martinique
en guadeloupe déboulonne des statues de
grands personnages français ils ont
déboulonné shell cher alors on pourrait
là encore argumenté sur celle cher moi
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
celle cher n'a pas à les déboulonner
mais ce déboulonnage là en réalité ce
n'est pas la statue qui est importante
et même le symbole qui est fait par
chercheurs qui était lui-même visé donc
mais mais mais exactement en réalité
situe en réalité c'est une attaque c'est
une attaque très clair envers les temps
10 ans aujourd'hui la situation qui est
la nôtre situation sociale le rapport
que nous avons à la france ce mépris
persistant
entretenu et par par l'état français je
dis bien par l'état français n'est plus
acceptable vous avez une jeunesse qui
est extrêmement conscient de sa réalité
extrêmement conscient de comment se
fait-il qu'il n'y ait pas un
développement endogène possible avec les
autres régions de la caraïbe comment se
fait-il que sur des terres vous l'avez
dit où le chômage est endémique très
fort où la pauvreté est la réelle
comment se fait-il que des produits de
première nécessité soient plus chers
qu'ailleurs comme si nous habitions
tchèque a permis plus cher qu'à paris en
tout cas plus cher qu'en région
parisienne effectivement comme si nous
étions au cap ferret ou ou à saint
tropez est donc là vous avez une colère
grandissante et avec une jeunesse encore
une fois qui est extrêmement qui
comprend connaît son histoire et qui est
très éduqués
[Musique]